the jurogan experience how old were you
when you had your first match like that
my first professional was 19 19. fight
king zulu with 120 fights
and four draws only 120 victories he was
a big guy too yeah about 210 to 20
and about
[Music]
yeah he was a big guy how much do you
weigh the time 174
those matches are still available online
people can watch them yeah it's pretty
cool i think so yeah
is it wild looking back at 19 year old
you
fighting zulu was a maybe the biggest
experience in my life because at this
point i felt like i was good i was able
to fight well
but i didn't have the experience
so and then one day i got home i saw my
father talking with his um
zulu's manager in brasilia
the capital
and the and the guy tried to bring to
invite my somebody's of my father team
to fight zulu
and my father was saying no i don't have
nobody we have to fight to valitude for
so long and nobody's training for
and i
i get the idea said hey dad pull me and
pull me and pull me in so i immediately
asked him to and he looked at me
and he mentioned to the to the other
mars antenna said yes but i have my son
here 19 years old do you want to try
and the guy said no mister master gracie
this is not a fight for him to try the
guy is very tough in this and
as the guy tried to pull my father off
the deal my father becomes more excited
through the no but i think he's gonna go
handle the challenge this and that so
he's become excited with the situation
so and then we set up the fight one
month later i was there to fight
and uh
[Music]
we start the fight
and he has a trade trade
like a
one move he does
which grab you with the hands between
your legs and lift you up and throw you
over the only back on the floor
and as you approach that i move back
block his his shoulders and hit him with
the knee
right on his face was the best knee i
could possibly give him somebody
and expect him to just
i expect to win the fighting right that
in that moment
but he just shook he he stood up lifted
his head shook
he spilled a tooth
and stuck back ready again to go
you know i and then i felt like was
really serious and the thing was much
serious than i expected
and for the next 10 minutes because was
10 minutes rounds
for the for the end of the round
we just engage and fall on the ring and
come back in and back in out and
a lot of a lot of commotion a lot of
strength
and in the end of the round i kind of
crawled into the corner
and i said to my dad dad i quit i know i
cannot go anymore i'm tired
and my dad not even listened to me said
yeah he's tired and you he's worse now
he's gonna kick his ass do this and that
said dad i'm serious man i'm dead
i cannot go
and then my brother holds throw me a
bucket of ice and water in my head i go
and then bang the route the bell rings
and i push in again
and like my dad said
i could beat the guy in three minutes
because he was already tired wasted
shoes so when i grabbed his back he
could not escape and i put him to sleep
and uh
and then i confirmed
my worst enemy was in my mind
was the
my enemy was
in my brain tell me i have to quit i
have to so i decide
and that day
never hurt my my mind tell
bad things to me anymore
so either i'm gonna die
or i don't go but if i go i cannot say
oh i think i had enough i think it's
time to so this was the worst enemy i
could have
and from that day on i decide to either
go to putting every tank on it or don't
go at all
so it was easier for me because i would
start to
to to deal with
one enemy only not two enemies my mind
and my opponent
it's probably the most common thing that
happens to fighters is they they lose
faith in themselves or they they start
to look for a way out yes
that's pretty much uh
because you don't see the other side you
see yourself and you see you tired you
see with problems you start to see the
negative aspects of you
and you're not
putting yourself like the guy has the
same problems he has the same ideas so
you have to keep going here as
everything is normal
and it's hard to
to people relate to that you know when
you start getting the problems you start
to see yourself bigger than the other
ones you know more problems and more
and that's not going to be the the right
way to resolve the matter it's
interesting that you figured out how to
handle these things
on your own too because this is uh
it's an area that fighters seek
psychological help with now they hire
psychologists and they they get
hypnotized and they do all these
different things to try to figure out
how to stop that negative conversation
in the mind how to stop those negative
voices and how to not give in to that
weakness that wants you to quit
yes this power we all have within
but some people don't even
go for that and they they seek for
different people to help them which is
good too
but once you become more
intuitive when you become more
enlighted with your own potential
you're able to resolve all the matters
yourself you know because it's all about
your mindset it's how you think and how
you believe and
what you
ready for and what you prepared for and
how are you able to
to accept and surrender everything
around you
and that these moments that where you do
want to quit whether it's in training or
in competition
for people who understand that and have
experienced that and have overcome it
life becomes easier
yes i think you know martial arts when
his practice with
with a complete idea
is a metaphor for life you know you
become a good martial artist you become
a good
person you go you're going to become a
happy person because you want to be able
to to conquer your your happiness
outside of the mat
and to deal with your demons yes
some people never fight those demons
they never so when something happens to
them in life some adversity comes up
they're not accustomed to handling it
yes
and we're seeing a lot of that now with
this uh pandemic
we're seeing a lot of people freaking
out because they've never really
experienced any true adversity in their
life
yes no it's not only for that but
because they don't ever thought about
how to resolve those problems you know
they just thinking
the problem is there what i'm gonna do
but they don't thinking about how i can
control the situation how i can be on
top of this how i can
you know just defend myself from those
demons and and
and if you don't see the perspective of
how i can resolve my problems
you allowed yourself to
to put your problems in somebody else's
hands to resolve for you
and it's all about perspective it's all
about focus
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify